so we have a wonderful viewer named
Marcin and by the way hi Marcin and
thank you for all your comments how do I
ask a connection for example a
successful screenwriter to help me break
into the business literally how do i
phrase it and what do i ask them for
exactly marcin that is a great question
first of all people who are successful
in the industry are very very busy and
if I wish you could see my desk because
I have literally probably 30 scripts on
my dust stacked up and they come from
there first of all there's the work
stuff that you have to read because
you're gonna either rewrite it or they
need you to read it for some reason or
other consulting jobs and then I have my
friends who I'm very close to who are in
my writers groups and I read their stuff
and they read mine and so we sort of
have this symbiotic relationship and
then there are the people I don't know
quite as well who send me scrubs to get
on that list is very difficult and what
a lot of new writers kind of don't
understand is that I don't have a lot of
free time and so you know if I'm gonna
spend any time at all
you know having a life I can't say yes
to everyone who asked me to read their
script because literally I probably get
a request a day to read someone's row so
that's a very tough thing so first of
all let me just say this don't get your
feelings hurt if someone says no they
can't read it for you or they can't help
you because they just can't and it's
just I just want to make that really
clear it doesn't mean that they're awful
people or they don't care about you or
they don't want you to be successful and
I think sometimes people take that wrong
and the best way to get people to read
your script is to network go to and
there are so many ways you can do it
join writers groups number one that's
the biggest thing have other people at
your level reading your script giving
you notes and then as you get better
they get better and then everyone sort
of can you sort of develop this network
of people that you can go to so that
you're not just cold calling asking
someone hey will you we read this
networking with people so that
you sort of do a favor for them and now
they owe you a favor so an example that
I sometimes give is go volunteer to Film
Festival you know it's it costs you
nothing you get to go you get to meet
everybody you get to meet all the
filmmakers that are there you get to
meet the people who are running it they
owe you a favor get to know them
volunteer to be on someone set go PA for
two weeks someone who comes in pas for
free for me for two weeks I'm much more
likely to say yes they're gonna get on
that pile versus someone I don't know
right so start building the network
first before you want to just hand off
the script because otherwise even if
they say yes a lot of times it takes
them months and months to read it and
then you're just kind of waiting and you
shouldn't be waiting you should be
moving on always be moving on to your
next project so that's my advice
yeah and in in a similar question as
Marcin has I knew someone who was upset
that a friend of hers did not help her
and was higher up on the sort of writing
food chain and was very upset about that
and I don't know how I feel about that
I've never asked anybody like that but
it would be a tricky situation and this
person was offended that the other
person didn't help them and I'm just
wondering what your thoughts are on that
because then there's a relationship at
stake yeah I think I think you have to
be careful about that because just
because someone's obviously higher up on
the food chain although I really don't
like that they're just further along on
their journey than you are and the thing
is is that that doesn't necessarily mean
they have the right contacts to help you
either and a lot of people don't really
understand that they think oh you must
be so well-connected or because I've
sold a lot like for lifetime they think
oh well you must know I if I give you
this script you can take it to lifetime
for me I do know what life time is
looking for because I work with them a
lot a lot of times that script isn't
what they're looking for so you know
even if it was a great script I know
it's not what they're looking for I
can't pass that on for you so there's a
lot of pieces of information you just
don't know it's very easy to get
resentful
I think in this because you work really
hard every writer does and sometimes it
takes a really long time for things to
pan out and so you're looking for any
means you can and anyone that will just
give you that leg up you know and and
I've been there and I get it
but you just have to be very careful
because I think that those things can
weigh on you a lot and when you start
getting too reliant on other people
doing things for you like oh well I
tried to give it to her but she wouldn't
pass it on and then so that was a
setback and then I tried to get my
friend to do this because he knows an
agent but he wouldn't look at it and
that was I think that you're doing
yourself a disservice so if you're
constantly looking for the next way for
you to develop the relationship with the
people you need to be meeting instead of
relying on other people you're just
going to be helping yourself down the
road and those relationships build over
years and at the end of that now you're
the person that people are coming to
interesting okay yeah thank you
you